once the screenwriter finishes a script
what are they doing with it they're
keeping it in a drawer and they're just
waiting for somebody there okay that's
what no and they're tweeting about it
they're tweeting about it I got a great
script well what you want to do is you
want to get it out into the world
absolutely and there's a couple of ways
to do that one is to send it to somebody
to give it to somebody who can give it
to somebody else who can give it to
somebody who's in a position to evaluate
it or possibly hire you or represent you
I've told this story many times about
Madonna's manicurist she goes on the
road with Madonna but when she wasn't on
the road she had a salon she worked in a
salon and there was a woman who came in
and was her customer her regular
customer and this woman had a son who
was a screenwriter and she would tell
the manicurist my son he's so talented
he's so talented and then one day she
said would you show his script to
Madonna and no would you read his script
and the manicurist said sure anybody
would you know everybody thinks they
know how to read a script so she read it
and she said you know what I think this
is really good and so the mom said would
you show it to Madonna
the manicure said yeah now she the
manicurist never gave it to Madonna she
gave it to Madonna's assistant but the
assistant read it and thought it was
good and then she actually gave it to
Madonna Madonna eventually this whole
thing took like a year she read it she
thought it was good and she gave it to
her agent and the agent thought it was
good brought the guy in and he got
representation so you never know you
know a friend of a friend of a friend
somebody who can get it to a junior
agent a junior manager a junior
executive or get it higher up if you
know somebody who knows somebody so you
want to launch it into the world you
also want to absolutely enter it into
contests but don't spend your money on
McGhee screenplay contests only do the
top
five or six prestigious ones because the
truth is the community is not looking at
the I don't mean to insult anybody at
the Idaho Falls screenplay writing
contest most likely they're not how
would you know is there a site or how
would you know which with the top yeah
to Google top screen writing contests
okay
you know it's certainly going to be
nickels it's going to be page it's going
to be Austin and there's there's final
draft there's others definitely go
online and just Google top ones there's
lots of sites that talk about the best
ones the ones I just mentioned are well
known and well received in television
there's tracking board which is really
good
that's the thing that Mickey Fisher
entered his on tracking be that's the
name of the site yes okay
you